[Música]
y
en cuando
[Música]
hasta
o jaulas
esa fue la pregunta que me hizo una
educadora hace un tiempo atrás
yo soy arquitecto de profesión y la
verdad que uno dice cómo le responde una
pregunta tan difícil a una educadora
cuando la realidad es que durante mucho
tiempo
hemos diseñado los espacios educativos
de la misma manera podríamos irnos
siglos atrás y podríamos ver que es
básicamente el mismo tipo de espacio
donde el profesor es el famoso filósofo
que está ahí arriba y el resto somos
todos tomados como iguales como si
fuéramos clones a mí me gusta mucho o
presentar esta pirámide porque habla la
zona de confort las zonas de confort que
generan las hileras donde la primera
hilera le llamo la zona caliente donde
estoy más cerca del del educador y donde
la atención puede ser óptima pero
conforme nos vamos alejando la verdad
que se va perdiendo la atención yo
cuando era estudiante solía sentarme
bien atrás porque realmente no me
interesaba lo que sucedía en la clase
así que está fuente de de información
unilateral
generó algo generó que diseñaremos
unidades que en este caso son aulas
donde hay un frente un frente que como
ya sabemos es el dueño es el profesor y
donde los alumnos realmente pues de la
pregunta sería si ellos no deberían
también tener una una pared
y es que cuando comenzamos a repetir
esta unidad se comienza a generar un
modelo de fábrica este vídeo de los años
70 es de pink floyd ejemplifica súper
bien la manera en que en que se han
generado las escuelas
y es que para diseñar cómo funciona una
escuela si alguien llega y me pregunta a
mí arquitecto cómo podemos diseñar una
escuela de la manera más tradicional
posible yo me podría fijar precisamente
en un plano por ejemplo de una cárcel y
quien no quita que pueda explicar cómo
funciona la escuela cuando dentro del
espacio viendo una imagen como la de
alcatraz donde tengo el pasillo central
y donde tengo las jaulas o las cárceles
perdón las aulas anulados
pero vivimos tiempos de cambio ahora el
centro de la atención tiene que girar
alrededor del aprendiz y ojo que la
aprendiz no solo el estudiante también
es el profesor
yo como arquitecto tuve la dicha de
estudiar en una universidad pública y
tuve un proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje
bastante interesante por el simplemente
el hecho de que el espacio era
completamente abierto no dijo que sea el
óptimo pero simplemente le hecho tener
un espacio completamente abierto me
genera mayores posibilidades que tener
una ratonera o un espacio cerrado
completamente
como aprendemos hoy
pues hoy aprendemos de maneras más
adaptables en espacios que sean más
multipropósitos de maneras más diversas
de maneras más expandibles e incluso más
interactivas pero para mí la pregunta
real es donde aprenderemos mañana
en incubadoras de aprendizaje
qué es una incubadora le pregunté a mi
hermana que es médica ella se considera
científica también y cuando le pregunté
ella me dijo una incubadora es el lugar
de gestación dónde
un lugar de gestación donde se crean las
bases para algo espectacular es la
definición que dio más bien mi amigo de
la artista s imagino no esta incubadora
ya les voy a mostrar que es imagino él
él se imaginó una incubadora de huevos
pero una incubadora de aprendizaje es un
espacio donde generamos momentos y
momentos especiales donde se puede dar
espacios de la transmisión espacios para
adquirir información espacios para
socializar para experimentar e incluso
algo que a veces dejamos de lado para
hacer un momento enfocado o un momento
donde tengo mi enseñanza aprendizaje
individualizada porque muchas de las
grandes ideas surgen cuando estamos con
nosotros mismos
ahora son 3
tres son los gran los grandes sectores
que necesitamos funcionar o yuxtaponer
para poder generar un aprendizaje
inmersivo y ellos son la pedagogía
el espacio y la tecnología
yo lo que les vengo a proponer hoy a
ustedes es cómo podemos hacer un cambio
en la manera en que diseñamos espacios
educativos en costa rica y no es con una
receta carísima realmente es con una
receta que cambia la manera en que
cocinamos estas fábricas esos cinco
ingredientes son enfrente
sin paredes
sin nombre
sin pasillos pero por rincones
sin frente es el momento en que cada
superficie que genera un espacio es una
superficie del estudiante es una
superficie de apoyo donde incluso hasta
el piso el piso puede ser la pizarra o
incluso un espacio de pizarra digital o
de vídeo mapping que hoy en día está en
tendencia tal vez en unos años cuando
veas está charla vídeo mapping va a ser
algo super antiguo y es que cada pared
puede ser variable puede ser utilizada y
debería ser de todos los aprendices
el ingrediente sin paredes quien no
quita que de repente cuando diseñamos
espacios con menos paredes hasta no
salga más barato
e incluso porque no dejamos de pensar
que los espacios funcionan para una sola
actividad porque no pensamos que ya es
hora de quitar las etiquetas a los
espacios y que el aula pueda convertirse
en un taller porque el espacio formal se
convierte a un espacio informal a la vez
porque el momento que no tenemos
pasillos
en el momento que no tenemos pasillos
todo espacio es un espacio de
enseñanza-aprendizaje
hoy en día estos proyectos que tengo la
dicha de poder diseñar en la firma en la
que trabajo realmente es uno de los
retos como de enseñar que incluso los
espacios al aire libre puedan ser
espacios donde los estudiantes los
aprendices los guías que son los
educadores puedan aprender
por ejemplo estas imágenes ustedes
pueden ver que cualquier espacio se
transforma en un anfiteatro o un espacio
taller realmente no hay una distinción
literal o lineal de pensamiento
tampoco podemos descuidar los rincones
porque los rincones son los que rompen
la monotonía cuando diseñamos esos
rincones pueden ser espacios así como
para tipos de enseñanza grupal o
aprendizaje así como espacios para
encerrarme y poder meditar y aprender de
mi propia manera que me guía me ayuda
así que los rincones tienen que aparecer
pero qué pasa si mezclamos los
ingredientes se podrán mezclar
hicimos un experimento en brasil donde
diseñamos una incubadora con todos estos
ingredientes básicamente nos fuimos y
agarramos 272 estudiantes y los metimos
en una incubadora ellos tienen su
espacio tradicional y cuando los metimos
en esta incubadora que tiene todos los
ingredientes nos dimos cuenta de cosas
muy interesantes porque
no solo nos metimos en incubadoras sino
que agarramos los medios del incubadora
y los metimos en sus aulas tradicionales
y medimos en términos de efectividad que
había mejorado cuando los poníamos en
las incubadoras y un 30 por ciento de
mejora de efectividad en todos sus
procesos tanto de estudio individual
como colaborativo e incluso el famoso
magistral
esta incubadora la diseñamos también en
brasil
realmente la incubadora paso a ser lo
que antiguamente se conocía como el aula
donde las las paredes son móviles donde
los espacios no sólo se funcionan entre
sí sino también se fusionan entre
pasillos este tipo de dinámica nos abrió
multitud de posibilidades para que los
aprendices mismos sean los que
transforman el espacio
pero les hago una pregunta será que es
solo los espacios educativos aprendemos
esta imagen es de un centro comercial en
colombia recientemente diseñamos una
incubadora donde nuestro nuestro cliente
se dio cuenta de que su negocio real a
pesar de que es una plataforma digital
realmente el valor nuevo hoy en día era
traer cc esa plataforma digital y
materializarlo un espacio físico dentro
de centros comerciales
y como pueden ver los rincones los
espacios sin pasillo sin paredes todos
comienzan a mezclarse
pero qué tal si nos vamos a una oficina
esta oficina está en dublín
realmente si yo no les digo que es una
oficina podría parecer que es una
universidad y una universidad con un
diseño súper exitoso espacios informales
se vuelve la marca de este edificio
y qué tal si nos vamos a manhattan este
proyecto lo diseñamos en conjunto con
otra firma arquitectos y al ser
manhattan no teníamos espacio para poner
un campus así que nació la idea del
campus en vertical y eso se volvió
completamente esa marca que necesitaban
ellos donde ustedes pueden ver que
realmente todo el espacio que comienza a
surgir en de manera vertical son sus
espacios con ingredientes
pero ustedes le pueden decir pero porque
este arquitecto no no se está hablando
de proyectos en costa rica si él es pico
bueno es porque está haciendo falta algo
muy importante hay tres actores que
todavía no nos ponemos de acuerdo
los políticos los arquitectos y los
profesores
realmente vimos una emergencia nacional
porque no podemos seguir gastando los
recursos de la manera en que seguimos
diseñando de manera tradicional la
verdad que ya llegó la hora de hacer el
cambio porque no es una cuestión de
dinero es una cuestión de cambiar la
manera en que pensamos
transformemos las jaulas en incubadoras
de aprendizaje muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]